think Rupert Murdoch and Fox News need
to do to regain some trust after what
we've learned about this and are you at
all concerned you can have an honest
conversation with Fox viewers oh oh I
don't think it's just Fox I I mean I'll
put them in there but all of media all
of Television media and everyone has to
own a little bit of the lack of trust
the lack of accountability it's okay to
get something wrong in the news but you
got to come back and own it and whether
it's fox or CNN or MSNBC or you know
whatever everyone just has to own it
intentionally lying to viewers though
that that to me seemed across the line
explain to me that look I'm not
defending anybody because I think you're
all you're all in the same basket I
really do but I could go to CNN when
they talk when they they're going to
ignore the the hunter Biden laptop story
we could talk about the virus coming
truly coming out of the lab in Wuhan
America is losing faith in media and you
guys have a huge opportunity to regain
that you're all in the same bucket
that's what he's saying at Chuck Todd
you all lie about everything